[Music]
and full of regrets news submitted by
barbell bright bringing regains yep
Justin Timberlake it's their gym and
that's the [ __ ] they call barbell
brigade Oh barbell brigades I get it
yeah that's cool yeah I get it
nice I love it all right Justin
Timberlake publicly apologizes to his
wife after a hand holding incident with
another woman I just saw him post
something I didn't know what was going
on but then I also didn't have the urge
to like let me go do it yeah I was just
like wow what's this I just scrolled
past what happened so what happened was
Justin Timberlake was Oh
Timberlake I thought you said Bieber
tymberlee changes things for me yeah I
said sounds like it's super squeaky
clean Wow Justin Timberlake and Jessica
Biel oh yeah are married they've been
married since 2012 let's just she's
[ __ ] hot how she's still hot they are
known to have one of the most rock-solid
marriages in Hollywood
mmm so they only cheat occasionally yeah
what a [ __ ] standard yeah they
actually stayed together guys oh my god
really they did know that god I think
when they first had their first kid or
whatever they are like [ __ ] Hollywood
[ __ ] all this crazy elation and they
moved to the middle of Montana and just
raise the kid for three years to get
some stability and then solidify their
relationship before they move back in
them and got and got more work that's
really smart because the kid won't
remember anything in Montana yeah but a
lot of people they can't wait they just
pop out the kid and really get back to
work yeah yeah he was seen with his
co-star Alicia Wainwright I mean I hold
her hands oh yeah she's not yeah so
there's difficult not to want to they're
filming for what I'm holding her hand
right he's just like would you rather
hold Jessica Biel's handle her like I'm
married to I think well what about you
probably Jessica Biel because I knew her
since I was in Middle School we have a
long youtube yeah
history I don't have anything was that
suburban with uh with Chuck in Larry or
with the one when she was in the fridge
like when she bent over in the fish oh
yeah that was no spank bank for me thank
babe I can tell sweet ass tight bud
alright so here's a video clip that the
tabloids got and so that's when you see
Justin and Alicia in New Orleans
where they were drinking a lot mm-hmm
those drinks man look how he's sitting -
oh yeah he said sure he said my they've
been drinking and look I'm gonna
probably [ __ ] you later he looks [ __ ]
wasted he looks so the paparazzi was
doing this yeah someone filmed it people
saw no paparazzi oh yeah she kicked the
feet over your legs she smoking soup
yeah I think so he telling her stories
like I don't both smoking hey like yeah
so one time I had to song called bye-bye
[Laughter]
did you know Britney cheated on me on me
with that [ __ ] that made the
documentary about Michael Jackson music
well sometimes when we did dick in a box
sometimes my dick was in the bud
sometimes no it might be in your box
later yeah so I have photos of that okay
so here we go let's get to the juicy
stuff put her hand on his knee motion
but when he was complaining about his
kids that's when she did that so there's
a the reporting that he grabbed her hand
put it on say I can't trust no there's
no video he has no video I guess this is
a photo of them holding hands oh no how
are they doing a role together yes Oh
actually they play like romantic well
you know this is research come on you
want to believe so bad look at you let's
practice not my JT me too why don't you
[ __ ] your co-star just to get used to
and comfortable just not cuz you wanna
[ __ ] them
it's method actor yeah right I do it so
here's the thing
the neat thing I can kind of pass
because it's like oh like like are you
silly
yeah but the whole day she had her hand
here and there yeah yeah so then after
this surfaced and then a couple weeks
went by and then Justin he ended up
posting this on his idea which I can
read it that's what I read it yeah I
stay away from gossip as much as I can
but it is for us for my family I feel
like it's important to address recent
rumors that are hurting the people I
love a few weeks ago I displayed a
strong lapse in judgment but let me be
clear nothing happened between me and my
co-star I drank way too much that night
and regret my behavior I should have
known better this is not the example I
want to set for my son I apologize to my
amazing wife and family for putting them
through such an embarrassing situation I
am focused on being the best husband and
father I can be this was not that I am
incredibly proud to be working on palmer
looking forward to continuing to make
this movie and excited for people to see
it all this he's so politically correct
it's delightful basically does he I
forgive him already he didn't do
anything in my house yet to me it all
depends on the relationship and like the
context cuz like let's say you know for
your urine Casey's bachelorette bachelor
party yeah everyone was drunk as [ __ ]
right so like let's say someone caught
me and you on the bench
arm over arm and we're just talking
remembering all the good times yeah and
then they take it out of context it can
be really friendly Oh anything on the
knee man but he gave it away because he
said I was the I apologize judgment
I guess it's better to admit it than to
try to be like it wasn't even like I
mean listen like sometimes your big
falls in places before we of course I
fought the pill bit me my friends gang
bang the couch one time yeah yeah no I
don't hear that part I thought I told
you there are other people involved your
friends were there no we all getting we
already what I said I [ __ ] the couch
and then you did jump in to the rescue
and someone okay because the bit in that
moment was to leave you because it was
funnier probably but I know I wasn't the
only the thing is like you know it sucks
about those situations like even when
stuff haven't we care for our stuff like
I'm trying I'm thinking about being a
guy cuz I've been in situations where
you think you did something like what is
your mom your girl and they say hey we
need to talk the amount of fear that
drapes over your butt so I can imagine
when that surfaced I know he's just
gonna bark room and just be like this
should take two like if I were in her
shoes I'm like oh no
cuz now people don't attack me they
thinking I'm trying to ruin [ __ ] can't
wait for the premiere with Jessica
Biel's they're saying like her people
were like she has a boyfriend in LA like
she doesn't mean [ __ ] it's just her
boyfriend is not jtq it is matt is gonna
be may we all know it's different but
it's like man it's tough like you gotta
you also have to know yourself you're
drinking you're already in this romantic
situation with this woman this whole
movie y'all don't need to be out
drinking again like you already know the
connections there claims they are doing
this movie so it's like you got it what
if it's to promote the movie hey come
and
I know about it because I didn't know
about it not even no conspiracy corners
we actually think that the show's name
is already being used but we don't care
consumers oh I think it is yeah and I
think it's by our friend to hear it I
don't necessarily think of them they
know everyone knows I've already had
people come to me in public about hey
real quick that's kind of like our
secret you know Club well you think the
house is like right now i think i think
it's felix like this is it is it thick
in there the atmosphere there's kind of
depends what kind of wife jessica biel
is well she's a woman
so she's probably scolding him a little
bit giving him a little silent treatment
but if she was like Hillary Clinton
she'd be like I don't give a [ __ ] what
you do just don't let it leak you know
yeah she's chucking furniture at the can
really yeah she threw furniture when the
Monica Lewinsky thing broke
I guess she chucked furniture at him not
because of what happened like with them
and her personally but because everyone
found out yeah because she was like I
told you is gonna catch up here's the
thing like Justin Timberlake now his
second part is he can literally not say
no he has to agree for everything oh
yeah and I need you go do this anything
like this love you the smart man that's
what Kobe did yeah okay we did that for
a year he caught off the hook yeah
Tiffany and company are hitmen [ __ ] was
it a brand deal at least or did you have
to pay for it every repair
that's why jewelry stores exist so cuz
guys keep [ __ ] up all the time I
think that's why relationships don't
last cuz when I [ __ ] up I'm just lop I
doing all this
[Applause]
somebody newly start fresh do I go about
my thing it just happened it's not
working cause I don't [ __ ] up so I don't
know that's all here she goes oh you
guys that's like crashing the car just
throwing the keys in there and be like
yeah it's ruined if I if I was
financially all well he would do this I
would do that if I crash the car I'm not
gonna get that fixed they do that in
Saudi Arabia I thought there's Lambos in
the desert and that's how I F five days
in the sand not yet they're like [ __ ] it
so why another one why didn't tiger do
that didn't Tiger like file a police
report because his wife chased him with
a golf club and and like beat up his
Chevy Tahoe or some [ __ ]
well yeah but I wouldn't have called
anybody oh that [ __ ] Tiger was going my
man like and they were a lot yeah I was
shocked he's a millionaire yeah but he
also looks kind of like a gay yeah but
he's a million him and Russell Wilson
are the same person I just don't know
what they are Russell wasn't a little
smoother you got to be a little smooth
to play quarterback you got to be a
little smile okay a little bit well he's
pretty goofy though I know you're
talking about he's goofy as [ __ ] the way
he ends every sentence look go Hawks I'm
like come on dude Jesus Christ I guess
that means there's enough money school
acts so you don't the suck the fans it's
that hard they like you they like you
okay
[Music]
[Music]